so you're just now starting to get into
crypto recently
yeah yeah yeah i've been following
crypto forever
bitcoin started around the same time
wall street bets did and i was like oh
this is kind of a cool
concept you know academics uh
idea behind this like you're gonna make
a currency this medium of exchange of
goods and services
uh it has all the properties of money
you know the bitcoin is gonna have
uh what do you call it it's gonna have a
cap is that it's gonna have scarcity
which is one of the components of
of money it's difficult to destroy
that's another component of money so
yeah why not
and i followed it along and i didn't
really get into it because there was a
lot of uh
execution and efficiencies behind there
if you wanted to do it
to get into bitcoin back then you really
had to devote some time into it
then as it became easier if i wanted to
get into bitcoin then it was still
the the execution was still not to my
liking as far as how long it takes to
settle this things with the spreads
between the bid and the ask
there was you know the fees between them
but the market matured a lot and it has
exploded to the point where
it's undeniable you have crypto spilling
into wall street and you have wall
street spilling into crypto
and and it's inevitable that those two
things are going to end up getting
married
you have bitcoin futures on the chicago
board of exchange
uh you have coinbase going public
which is symbolic but it still is still
further evidence that it's a legitimate
uh universe and then you have
stocks that you can now start buying
through crypto synthetic homes
synthetic stocks you want to buy tesla
for example uh
it's difficult or inaccessible to a lot
of the people around the world but now
they can just buy a token
and then somebody else behind the scenes
goes and buys the share and then those
two prices
basically match what you would so those
those universes are
marrying and i'm super excited about the
possibilities
do you think the government's ever going
to try to regulate crypto
yeah they do already you know every time
like so i create a wallet it's like all
right you want a wallet sure here's your
address
be happy being anonymous i'm like oh
this is pretty cool now i want to buy
something with this right or
it's something like being here in mexico
i'm like okay this one allows me to take
my bitcoin and put it into
uh pesos into my bank account so i
download this app and says all right
good congratulations you have this thing
we'll deposit in your account
um you can do 200 bucks a month 200 a
month from your from your
uh broker to uric bank and i'm like well
that's not very much money
so there's a button that says okay you
want to put more money tell us more
about yourself
put a picture of your id you want more
money sure tell us like the sources of
income
you want more money tell us your social
security number the equivalent here
so the more and more that i want to
participate with this the more and more
the government gets involved with it so
i think
and that's the same in the u.s like the
closer you get that
internet money to a brick-and-mortar
bank the more the government
uh gets involved and so i think that
they're they've done a decent job with
it and i think they'll continue doing it
because there's a lot of
uh innovation taking place and it takes
place really rapidly
and so most likely the government's
going to want to regulate and with good
reasons i don't think regulation is
always a bad thing necessarily
what do you think though about like the
government's ability to print money and
inject it into the economy and
the fda with all inflation and deflation
and all of that stuff
like how do you think the future of
crypto is going to affect
the financial world as we know it in
that aspect it's good
i think it's going to live side by side
it's never going to take it over it's
the language when bitcoin started it
this was fresh
right out right right out of the
financial crisis with the occupy wall
street movement so a lot of language was
like oh screw the fed and they're
printing money and inflation and the
manipulation or whatever we're going to
take them down make them obsolete um
you know it's it's cute but it's not
gonna happen ever it's
it's uh there's just too much on the
other side and too much power on the
other side but they can live side by
side
and they can complement each other very
well
i think crypto can push uh mainstream
banking into being
more competitive just just like robin
hood forced normal brokers to be free
and also more competitive
bitcoin is going to make it so that if
you want to transfer funds
internationally it's much faster easier
and cheaper
than what the banks offer if you want to
settle if i want to check in at cash
right now if i want to
clear a check it takes three days for
the bank to settle it and then people
say well but if you have good credit the
bank will lend you money it's like i
don't want to borrow money i want this
check to have the funds from that
account now and and so
uh the more people go towards crypto to
get around these
inefficiencies the more banks banks are
going to have to get their act together
this isn't facebook getting his ass
kicked right now by google there's like
a big war between facebook and google
right now
and and are you do you stay up to date
with any of that stuff
of course yeah i don't know i'm very up
to date with everything but it's like
these questions are
can be shallow or very deeply
philosophical they don't
they don't do the same stuff like
facebook uh
is a social network at heart right they
collect information they put out ads and
they're very effective with doing that
that's kind of their business model
uh they have a huge audience and google
has their google's
in a little bit of everything for
starters they have the search engine so
it's kind of like the
portal to the internet that's probably
their bread and butter but then they're
at
everything else they're in artificial
intelligence they have phones they have
hardware like
they're doing cars they're doing uh you
name it they're
they're getting into it so it they're
they don't directly compete with each
other the
the google tried several times to get
into the social
uh network and they failed miserably
every time trying to take on facebook so
they just gave that up and they're no
longer going to try doing that anymore
so i don't know that they can
they'll overlap sometimes but they're
different i'm sorry i was just reading
an article in the new york times i think
it was about uh
apple versus facebook ah yes where
facebook didn't want app
apple is gonna put some sort of
technology update in their phones where
they can opt out of
um they can opt out of facebook tracking
them from app to app
and facebook's pissed off because they
want to be able to do that because they
say that's how they can most effectively
market to people
is that they can follow them from app to
app yeah it's pretty crazy because like
you're kind of at the mercy these these
these i can just call it at let's call
facebook an app for now
you know facebook is at the mercy of
apple we saw
what was it with fortnite it's a video
game that was really popular
and they got in this scuffle with apple
because of money
and apple decided to take them off of
their the play store you can't use
fortnite on your phone anymore
uh they have the ultimate say they're
like sorry for terms of service we
decided we're the gatekeeper so sorry
about your luck
you know so the companies have to kind
of play this game where they're like all
right fine we'll comply with your
service because we have to you know
apple has
half the market out there and you can't
try to piss them off
but yeah they're they're going at each
other so apple's making all sorts of
things to try and create privacy uh
conscious you know they're trying to
protect privacy that's kind of kind of
their latest uh
direction they're taking things in in
facebook's model relies on
no privacy so they are kind of crashing
a little bit in that regards
uh so you know we'll see how it plays
out
facebook even though it's the mercy of
apple is still extremely powerful
because
uh people are just as married to
facebook as they are to their iphone
so i i'm guessing that they're all using
that as a
bargaining chip they're like fine don't
put facebook on your phone see how many
people drop iphone and then people
the iphone say fine i'm not gonna put
facebook on my phone and see how many
people drop facebook so
we'll we'll see what happens probably
somewhere in the middle they'll
negotiate some middle
middle route maybe some more little
agreements you have to check yes i agree
i don't know
they'll they'll solve it i don't i don't
think it's going to be a big issue
but new i mean news like this i mean
must affect the stocks
of each of those companies i mean
personally my outsider
perspective is that like i can't see
i can't see the future of facebook being
that bright
because i don't i don't personally don't
know many people that use facebook that
are under the age of 50. and it just
seems like
facebook is just this crazy
message board of outrage and and old
old people fighting about politics yeah
you know and i agree with you i haven't
i haven't been on facebook
effectively for about a decade you know
i got on there
shortly after i got married several
years ago to put pictures of my wedding
so that my
friends could see what they looked like
and and i locked in put the pictures
locked back out i haven't been back in
there since i
i feel you with that one um i think that
any
the nature of social networks as a whole
is whatever's in style
snapchat was real big for a while i
haven't heard a lot of buzz on that
anymore it seems to be tick tock's the
big one nowadays
uh you know there was one that was what
was the one that was also videos the
short videos
vine vine would lasted for a little
while that was super cool you know but
that came and went really quickly so
it's the nature of the beast so
whoever's in charge of the social
network twitter obviously
instagram um they'll be changing it's
and i agree with you
but the facebook does have an advantage
which is they have a lot of users and a
lot of active users just because you or
i
don't use it or know people that do use
it sorry we do know people that use it
they're our mom and dads very
like they're uncles but just because we
don't interact doesn't mean that there's
a lot of
potential the fact is that facebook has
so much information
the mere fact that you downloaded the
app on your phone and you have it
and it's tracking you like facebook
knows things and with that knowledge
they can
do stuff with it and turn that into
money magically uh
they they do still have a ton of power
with the ability to target advertising
with the ability of target demographics
um google has that same ability
i think that facebook does need to
innovate
and and and uh although their big bread
and butter
is uh their original platform
that's probably why they buy up you know
instagram and i think they bought
snapchat at some point you know like
they
they that's their effort to try and stay
on top just buy whichever one is popular
at the time we'll see what happens but i
agree i don't i don't know that they
have a promising future but their
present is very promising
i